oh happy friday
i'm not your doctor but i can heal you
so what a week for free speech
first elon musk buys twitter so all
sides could be heard he's like a cop in
a movie who opens the trunk of a car to
find a person bound and gagged whose
screams couldn't be heard because
someone put duct tape over their mouth
who hasn't been there right
and my school for twitter is like mine
at the planet fitness steam room
if it's legal have at it
but then the white house announces a
ministry of disinformation to monitor
your speech as if they're the parents
and you're a newborn in a crib in the
next room
so the people lying want to be the
arbiters of truth that's like seth
meyers deciding what's funny
you're not going to believe this here's
the lady who's running the thing
information laundering is really quite
ferocious it's when a hopster takes some
lies and makes them sound precocious by
saying them in congress or a mainstream
outlet so disinformation's origins are
slightly less atrocious
it's how you hide all the light of light
it's how you hide a little light a
little lie it's how you hide a little
idol's live when rudy giuliani shared
that intel from ukraine or when
tick-tock influences say covet can cause
pain they're laundering disinfo and we
really should take note and not support
their lies with our wallet voice or vote
well that's it for us
tonight you know what
maybe she's right some forms of speech
should be banned
so now the government thinks your speech
is dangerous them
which is ironic coming from people whose
poor choice of words were responsible
for people dying during covid or whose
words are responsible for sending young
people off to die in pointless wars
the government now holds the reigns on
truth
reigns not whips
like in recent disinformation from the
government and it's weird to see who's
happy and who isn't about elon musk
when elon musk says wow this is about
free speech it seems to me that it's
about free speech of straight
white men the right has already seized
is this ground that they're on the side
of free speech they're really not
they're for the political version of
healing fire in a movie theater elon
musk i guess he you know he misses the
old south africa in the 80s he wants he
wants that back elon musk buying twitter
says a lot about the priorities of
people at the highest levels
making decisions that could affect the
fate of the planet the fate of the
planet i haven't seen them this unhappy
since
[Applause]
but these are people in the media
melting down and why well they want to
control the marketplace of ideas and it
makes sense because this isn't about who
can speak it's about who can be heard
when anyone can speak their mind why
would you listen to nicole wallace
but come on as much as they dislike my
opinions and as much as i make fun of
their weight you'd assume we'd all agree
on our right to say these things we're
the free press
sure i think brian stelter's an idiot
but i'd never censor him just because he
stinks of buttermilk pancakes
we're in the same business we talk for a
living rachel maddow should have the
right to lie about russiagate and i
should be able to lie to geraldo that
i'm allergic to hot tubs
but instead they're telling us that the
first amendment's up for grabs after all
why should the second amendment be the
only one the media and government abuse
soon the only right we'll have left is
that we can't be compelled to shelter
british soldiers
although i'll make an exception for you
douglas
don't worry the coach the couch is a
fold-out yeah and not just the couch
but it's all about left-wing conformity
and their consolidation of power
and we saw it coming with hate speech
laws speech codes and safe spaces but we
lamely thought that it would be
contained on campus and now the only
thing the left wants free after college
is student loan debt
so how did this all seep into real life
well i underestimated the fear these
freaks could instill in others we didn't
realize how much weight calling you a
racist could bear on them they say it's
tantamount to michael moore sitting on a
newborn baby's chest for 45 minutes
and we us
underestimated how many cowards would
cave in to this form of domestic
terrorism
that's right canceling people's lives
because of something they said is
terrorism not raising your voice to a
school board you jackasses
so unlike the summer of love the left
today didn't turn on tune in and drop
out they applied for jobs in big
companies and they got them netflix
twitter disney world even my masseuse
has four pronouns i never use them
everywhere that you see a decline in
freedom or fun there they are they even
ruined star wars
i know cat
it reminds north korean defectors of
home
they now target stuff that was off
limits your parenting abilities your
health your job your safety you know
things that used to come under the
category of none of your business
and everything you say
is now a tripwire i'd say booby trap but
i don't want to get hauled into hr
this isn't feeling like america and
maybe that's the goal they never liked
this place to begin with but instead of
leaving they're trying to recreate what
immigrants escape from
tyranny authoritarianism fascism they
focus on bureaucrats media cowards with
power and replace them with little
tyrants dedicated to the left-wing hive
mind and now hate speech is all speech
except theirs it's weird to see a free
press embrace this it's like surgeons
disavowing the hippocratic oath it's
like athletes denouncing winning it's
like me condemning sculpted pecs
so they chose the worst position
because they aren't yours and condemn
things only because you might be for
them this happens when you make the
political personal they go after cops
moms dads kids and now speech what could
be next you can say a lot about these
leftist a-holes but unambitious ain't
one of them and with enemies like that
who needs russia
let's go
tonight's guest he's wider than a
cauliflower sandwich on wonder bread fox
news contributor tom shalou
and he can be my lord of the manor any
day of the week fox news contributor and
author of the great new bestseller the
war on the west
douglas murray
her lab can guide ships in the fog
fox news contributor captain
and the man no one can pick up wrote a
book no one can put down my massive
sidekick in the nwa's world television
champion
tom you sing in a barbershop quartet yes
you finally found somebody you can
actually mock
this lady because that was just wait a
minute i don't know where you're going
with that well normally people would
make fun of you but now you can i mean
there's nothing quite like that was
horrendous it was really quite amazing
and i mean she is a ridiculous person
and we are all laughing at her and in
fact i think that the the whole the
whole country will laugh at her but you
can't forget it's not
just that she's a ridiculous person
because serious people are doing what
she's doing as well right the other day
i heard obama say the same thing obama
said you know i'm a free speech
absolutist but you can't say things that
aren't true yeah
that's not true that's the whole idea
you can say things that aren't true and
like nicole wallace said i'm sick of
hearing that phrase about the theater oh
you can't yell fire in a theater yeah
you can you can yell fire in a theater
for many reasons one when there's a fire
in a theater two when you think there's
a fire in a theater i mean you're
allowed to say things so you're allowed
to be wrong and just like you said when
obama says something when he we used to
do shows obama would say something and
then we would say no i disagree with him
and we we talk about it and that's the
essence you are allowed to say things
that aren't true i think these people
have failed before they've begun this
thing is idiotic and i don't think
anyone is going to take it seriously so
i'm right now i'm celebrating that i
feel like this
disinformation board has failed before
it's begun you're absolutely right i
always yell fire in a theater when ryan
gosling's on screen
douglas
how did the democrat end up on the wrong
side of this it's kind of crazy well
remember they spent ages saying that
free speech was a right-wing dog whistle
and that like like everything else it
was arriving so they've just decided to
come out against free speech
and uh and yeah i mean
nobody could perform this task i mean
you know i would say like find me name
me the person you think should decide
what all of us can say read know hear
there's no such person no such person in
the land
but this lady yes
i mean of all the ones you get the mary
poppins weird disinformation song person
who also has been wrong
on so many things didn't she she thought
the hunter biden laptop story should uh
be suppressed yeah she said that it was
a product of trump's campaign right she
also defended that letter of from the
like the 50 intel people yeah all lying
yeah yeah so she was she's so she's
already she's been wrong on the big
stories and when jen sake and others
defend this ridiculous new board you
know i just want to say well how about
you
you you said that
they weren't taking people from the
southern border and shipping around the
country in the middle of the night
because it was 3 a.m and that doesn't
count as the middle of the night or
something like that that was it yeah
they lie all the time they spread
misinformation everyone in my experience
who talks about misinformation
obsessively is the one doing it yeah
yeah
tyrus this feels like a great week if
you love free speech right like if
you're if let me if you're unhappy
politically about what happened this
week you might want to rethink your
politics like if you if this bothers you
yeah well
i think it's sad that we have to be
excited about someone saying hey let's
just be normal yeah let's just hey
everyone just police yourself and yeah
agree to disagree or you disagree but
everyone gets a voice that shouldn't be
a big thing i think the the
horribleness is julie andrews what did
she do yes
what did she do to deserve to be mocked
like that that was
that was brutal a remix or whatever but
and i disagree a little bit somebody
could
or someone's could do be on a board of
disinformation if they own their own
so if she would have came out and said
i did this silly well you know i
wouldn't own that i would i would i
would make up a lie and say i was my
kids were being kidnapped and they said
i had to sing this song otherwise
everyone died and luckily everyone lived
so i did my part but what i'm saying if
she would have came out and said listen
i was wrong about the hundred button
thing and i'm gonna make sure that when
you're wrong about something it doesn't
mean it goes away
but that would take a really really
brave and honest person probably a
billionaire who doesn't gain anything
yes that's yeah that the fact that she
could could take this job with that
without admitting that she's because
she'll double down on that stuff yes yes
yes so she's disqualified cat you hate
freedom and you hate speech
so talk freely talk freely
isn't it funny though to see democrats
coming out against something like this
it's just weird everything is turned
upside down yeah i
i i'm having a hard time understanding
this i mean it's just objectively
ridiculous to have this you know
anti-disinformation board
led by someone who is famous for
spreading disinformation i don't
understand how everybody is not pissed
off about this and pointing out how
absurd it is
uh and you know if you're the reason
you're not is because this is a
democratic administration and you're a
democrat then like you're
you're too stupid for there to even be
words for that because obviously it's
not always going to be a democratic
administration right and obviously when
the government creates something doesn't
really usually go away after that so
when it's not a democratic
administration this will still be there
yeah i i don't understand how everybody
is not upset about this you know i think
that uh dana made a good point on the
five yesterday very rare
that like
democrats don't have somebody that's
sensible to tell them this was a bad
idea they've gotten rid of all those
people but because somebody could say
dude this sounds just like 1984 and
they'll be go they'll be going what's
that you know but they would like
somebody would say this is the minute
what are they called the ministry of
truth was that what it was called and
and and would would tell them how stupid
but there's nobody there to tell these
wokesters they they they don't have a
history a
don't think it's happening i don't think
the board can't happen b
if they do it she doesn't have a job
that's the only way they can attack elon
yeah this is all about going after elon
yeah that's true
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else